oh
[Musique]
ni même en europe ce n'est pas la
meilleure période de l'année pour nos
boules de plumes favorite s'est froissé
humide les sources de nourriture se font
rares bref si la cat a fortiori dans les
oiseaux ont besoin d'avoir de la
ressource mais aussi un peu de chance ce
qui n'est pas toujours le cas
c'est la raison pour laquelle de
nombreuses espèces choisissent de
quitter l'europe pour des climats plus
clément et voyages sur des milliers de
kilomètres malgré les dangers qu un tel
périple représente
c'est vous dire si la situation en hiver
pour les oiseaux est catastrophique
l'un des principaux facteurs de
mortalité chez les oiseaux en hiver
c'est la raréfaction des sources de
nourriture
en clair il n'y a plus grand chose à
manger les insectes sont cachés
hibernent parfois les fruits sont tous
tombés est déjà pourri les noix et
noisettes ont déjà été récoltés et les
graines aussi donc pour se nourrir les
oiseaux doivent déployer des trésors
d'ingéniosité
c'est là que nous pouvons intervenir à
condition bien sûr de savoir quoi faire
et approcher une mangeoire sur son
balcon ou dans son jardin ça peut faire
toute la différence pour plusieurs
dizaines de plumes
aujourd'hui ils ont donc tous intéressés
aux mangeoires et à leur contenu
parce qu avant d'accrocher le soleil et
de mamies dans les branches du premier
arbre venu
mieux vaut se renseigner un peu et
d'abord on met quoi dedans une main
noire
[Musique]
il s'agit de décider quelles espèces
d'oiseaux vous voulez privilégiées tous
les oiseaux ne mange pas la même chose
et c'est parfois très différents on peut
ainsi trouver les oiseaux qui mange des
graines des fruits des insectes du
nectar des noix du poisson des souris et
parfois même d'autres oiseaux
il ne vous ruez pas sur le son de mamie
pour le jeter dans le précédent que sa
lettre
lorsque selon l'endroit où vous êtes
il n'est pas dit que des espèces
piscivores habitent dans le coin non ce
qui est plus probable c'est que vous
allez avoir de nombreuses espèces
insectivores et granivores autour de
chez vous les espèces carnivores sont
les plus simples pour débuter nous
allons donc commencer par celle ci et
pour ces espèces
vous pouvez leur proposer et crel sa
demande au pot de crème
il existe dans le commerce de nombreux
mélange de thann pour oiseaux tout près
souvent avec du miel et du maïs concassé
certains mélanges rajoute aussi des
graines de tournesol très énergétique
est particulièrement utile en hiver
lorsque les oiseaux ont besoin de lutter
contre le front ce que je vous conseille
si le mélange de graines que vous
achetez n'a pas de graines de tournesol
c'est simplement d'acheter un paquet de
graines de tournesol à côté et de
mélanger tout
[Musique]
là c'est un peu à [ __ ] décidé je ne
connais pas toutes les marques de
graines pour oiseaux et puis même si
c'était le cas ce choix est très
personnel je conseille tu n'aimes
d'essayer d'éviter des graines qui ont
poussé avec des pesticides
on n'est pas exactement certains des
effets de ces composants sur les oiseaux
mais par contre on sait que lors de la
culture de ces crèmes ça a certainement
éradiquer les tonnes d'insectes et
d'autres arts vertébrés et de mon point
de vue c'est un peu bizarre d'essayer de
sauver quelques espèces en moins sa
crainte des milliers d'autres si vous
voulez attirer d'autres espèces
d'oiseaux vous pouvez aussi proposer
d'autres types de graines comme les
graines de niger de petite laine noire
est allongé particulièrement apprécié
par les chardonnerets ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que différentes espèces
dont avoir des goûts différents
je pars gardait des souris mortes dans
mon frigo rien pour toi
rien que d imaginer série entre les
gouttes et la salade à l'élevage de
sevrier vivante à la maison bien sûr
autres composants à mettre dans une
mangeoire les noix beaucoup d'espèces
raffole des cacahuètes ou des noix de
cajou et si vous avez la possibilité
vous verrez que les mésanges notamment
en sont très friandes
alors attention je parle bien ici de
noix et d'arachide non salés ni mélange
qu'on peut acheter pour l'apéritif du
sel et le plein d'idées qui sont
évidemment à proscrire
petite remarque si vous stockez les
arachides style cacahuètes
pensez à bien le faire dans un endroit
propre et sec exposées à l'humidité les
arachides peuvent parfois développé un
champignon qui sécrète à son tour une
molécule appelée aflatoxines c'est
particulièrement toxique pour les
oiseaux en fait c'est bien simple si un
oiseau mange des cacahuète contaminé à
l'aflatoxine il ya de fortes chances
pour qu'ils en meurent oui mais c'est
plutôt radicale général donc dans le
doute ne stockait pavot cacahuètes
pendant trop longtemps acheté les en
petite quantité et si elles ont un petit
air de moisi qui prouve l autre contenu
à mettre dans une mangeoire les uns
c'est alors c'est un peu plus compliqué
à trouver mais parfois certaines marques
proposent des insectes déshydraté très
facile à utiliser
tu n'en lemieux juste encore les
insectes vivants oui c'est en
supermarché ça risque d'être compliqué
le meilleur moyen de trouver des
insectes vivants c'est encore les
animaleries souvent ils ont ce qu'on
appelle des vers de farine qu'on donne à
manger aux échos ou hérisson et c'est
bien de farine peuvent tout à fait être
utilisé pour les oiseaux et vous verrez
que c'est souvent les quelques vers de
farine que vous mettrez dans la
mangeoire qui disparaissent en premier
finalement les oiseaux en raffolent là
tout de suite je ne sais pas de nourrir
des rapaces là évidemment les biens de
farine sa célèbre aussi très facilement
à la maison si vous ne voulez pas
retourner à l'animalerie toutes les
semaines
il ya plein de tuto sur le net je vous
encourage à y jeter un oeil si vous avez
le temps et puis de toute façon il est
fort probable que je fasse une petite
vidéo sur le sujet d'ici peu que je
mettais sur twitter donc si ça vous
intéresse allez donc y jeter un oeil
enfin la mangeoire à oiseaux peut aussi
servir de plateau de fruits frais
beaucoup d'espèces sont un régime
alimentaire incluant des baies pour des
fruits quand la saison le permet car ce
sont des aliments qui sont très riches
en sucre en hiver il est possible de
proposer les tranches de pommes ou des
quartiers d'orange qui seront aussi très
apprécié mais attention à ne jamais
donner d'avocats
c'est un poison pour les oiseaux
n'oubliez pas non plus de nettoyer
régulièrement à la mangeoire si vous
donnez des fruits tout ce qui est
aliments frais peu moisir et développer
les champignons et bactéries s'y laisser
trop longtemps à l'aide
enfin un dernier aliments qui a toute sa
place sur une mangeoire c'est le fameux
pain de graisse se voir vernis de grêle
il sert de bar d'énergie pour tous les
oiseaux qui ont bien besoin d'un petit
boost en hiver pour résister au froid
on peut évidemment les acheter tout près
dans le commerce sous forme de tranches
ou de boules mais c'est aussi possible
de le faire soi même avec la recette que
nous allons vous donner maintenant dans
cette recette il vous faudra un saladier
une cuillère à soupe des récipients
petits pots de yaourt moules à muffins
ou même une assiette pour y poser les
boules de graisse une cuillère à soupe
de graines
alors ici j'ai un mélange de graines
vous pouvez mettre des graines de
tournesol ce que vous avez sous la main
ce n'est pas bien grave
une cuillère à soupe de beurre de
cacahuète sans sel sans sucres ajoutés
et bien entendu sans additif une
cuillère à soupe de flocons d'avoine
idem sans additif 5 cuillères à soupe de
graisse végétale sans additif aussi
essentiel donc de la margarine de
préférence sans huile de palme ou alors
éco responsable à on n'est pas là non
plus pour privilégier les oiseaux aux
orangs outans vous pouvez aussi d'un
remplacé par du cuivre de porc ou de
boeuf a trouvé en boucherie ni beurre ni
crème à savoir que les oiseaux ne digère
pas le lactose
étape 1 dans le récipient verser les
différentes graines puis le beurre de
cacahuète et enfin la grèce mélanger le
tout la graisse végétale est un aliment
riche en lipides très énergétiques pour
les oiseaux qui va leur permettre de
résister au froid
étape numéro 2 mettez le mélange dans le
pot de yaourt ou le moule à muffins que
vous avez sorti on vous paie aussi le
façonner enfin de grèce si vous le
mettez dans un moule à cake par exemple
il vous suffira ensuite de couper des
tranches
étape 3 places et la boule de graisse
dans le réfrigérateur pendant quelques
heures en fonction de la taille de votre
boule de graisse ou de votre pain de
grèce peut-être falloir plus de temps
pour que ça se solidifie correctement
étape numéro 4 une fois la grèce
solidifier placez la dans une mangeoire
spéciale à boules de graisse ou dans un
récipient
petite astuce pendant que vous façonner
le pain de grèce vous pouvez aussi
prévoir d'insérer une
ficelle ou un crochet pour faciliter
l'accrochage petite précision concernant
les boules de graisse que vous pouvez
trouver dans le commerce
elles viennent souvent entouré d'un
petit filet alors outre le fait que
lorsque la boule de graisse est finie le
filet a tendance à s'envoler et à
polluer le milieu naturel
ça ne se décomposent pas vu que c'est
ferran nylon les oiseaux peuvent aussi
se prendre deux dents et parfois restés
coincés les pattes en mêlée dans l'émail
et même s'il n'en meurt pas toujours ils
peuvent aussi se blesser et perdre un ou
plusieurs doigts
donc si vous achetez ce genre de boules
de graisse n'oubliez pas de bien retirer
le filet avant de les suspendre
[Musique]
ça m'arrange imaginait pas du tout c'est
un terreau sets de cuisine quand j'ai
commencé les miss prime en marché et
maintenant qu'on sait à peu près quoi
mettre dans une mangeoire voyons
ensemble quelle contenant peut
accueillir ces contenus il existe des
centaines de ce type de mangeoires
différents donc je vais juste vous
présenter quelques design que je trouve
intéressant au moins pratique
mais évidemment n'hésitez pas à tester
d'autres formes il ya plein d'idées sur
le net
amusez vous alors bien sûr vous pouvez
simplement juste acheté une mangeoire
mais fait juste attention à ce qu'elles
soient totalement sans danger pour les
oiseaux ni fil de fer mal placé ni pique
en bois un peu trop pointu mais avant de
faire les magasins pourquoi ne pas en
faire une petite avec ce que vous avez
chez vous et si ensuite ça vous plaît et
que vous avez toujours envie d'améliorer
votre matériel vous pourrez toujours
investir danger de mangeoires un peu
plus pro ou quoi qu'il en soit
rassurez-vous les oiseaux ne
s'arrêteront pas à l'emballage
ils sont surtout intéressés par ce qu'il
ya avec les deux ans donc aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous proposer de réaliser
votre propre mangeoire avec des
matériaux recyclés ou de vieux trucs qui
traînent par chez vous j'ai sélectionné
quatre types de mangeoires différents et
c'est à vous de choisir ce que vous
préférez
la première c'est une mangeoire fait
avec une bouteille d'eau et des
cuillères en bois ou en plastique
[Musique]
mangent l'irak montrent qu'ils fouillent
dans les poubelles
je te propose une bouteille en plastique
elle est lavée elle est propre là c'est
vrai on va pas se mentir on est sur du
vraiment basique mais qui reste
fonctionnel malgré tout pour le matériel
il vous faudra une bouteille en
plastique de 50 centilitres 3 grande
cuillère en plastique de la colle de la
ficelle et des ciseaux prenez une
bouteille en plastique père saisit des
trous de part et d'autre de manière à ce
que les cuillères en plastique que vous
insérez dans ces trous soit légèrement
penché du côté de la cuillère les
troupes doivent être suffisamment haut
pour laisser passer des graines mais pas
trop large pour que les cuillères ne
tombe pas sécurisé la cuillère avec un
point de colle de chaque côté versez
ensuite le bouchon est inséré la ficelle
qui vous servira à suspendre la
bouteille ne collait pas le bouchon sur
la bouteille car ce sera par là que vous
pourrez la remplir de graines et voilà
votre nouvellement joueur est prête à
être suspendu
[Musique]
simple efficace et parfait comme
activité déco pour les enfants pas de
confinement
que demander de plus pour le matériel il
vous faudra un pack de lait 1 litre vide
évidemment des ciseaux de la ficelle de
la peinture acrylique un pic à brochette
mais ça peut aussi marcher avec des
baguettes en bois si vous avez
évidemment de la colme ouvrez votre pack
de lait selon le schéma à l'aide des
ciseaux
rincez bien jusqu'à ce que toute trace
de l'est et disparus planté là piques à
brochettes en dessous de l'ouverture de
manière à ce qu'elle ressorte un peu de
l'autre côté donc ça aide à la maintenir
en place et ensuite coller la percer un
trou en eau du pack de préférence au
milieu et fait passer la ficelle vous
pouvez ensuite décoré et en faire une
jolie maison laissée bien sécher avant
de remplir de graines et de suspendre il
vous reste un vieux service à thé dont
toutes les tasses son chip et mamie nous
a fait don de tout s'est tu as
dépareillé et franchement la coupe tard
voici de quoi les recycler pour le
matériel
il vous faudra une vieille cassette et
avec soucoupe une perceuse de rondelles
en inox de préférence dont vous voyez en
fonction du diamètre de votre corde et
de la taille de la tasse de la corde et
et ciseaux et enfin de la colle cette
mangeoire peut suspendre ou simplement
se poser sur un mur et c'est à vous de
voir
moi j'aime bien la version suspendu et
puis en plus on peut lui ajouter une
deuxième assiette sur le dessus ça fait
quand même un petit parapluie c'est très
sympa
prenez votre tasses et soucoupes et
percé au centre de chacune coller
ensuite l'une sur l'autre en faisant
attention à bien aligner les trous
ensuite passé la corde dans le trou de
la dass et de sa soucoupe fait d'un
noeud en dessous ajoutez une rondelle
sur le dessus pour bien faire mais la
tasse et enfin que les graines ne tombe
pas une fois la tasse suspendu il ne
vous reste plus qu'à approcher cette
mangeoire à la branche qui vous plaît et
les oiseaux ont en leurs services à thé
peut désigner
il existe aussi une variante accrochez
une plaque en bois pour pouvoir la
suspendre au mur j'ai pas mal
et puis ça fait très ardue comme on les
aime bien
jussiê tout simple mais il peut être
très décoratif et puis c'est parfait
pour recycler les vieux pots en terre
cuite deux derniers échecs en matière de
jardinage un plutôt que de les laisser
moisir en un coin pas remise non non ne
me remerciez pas c'est cadeau pour le
matériel il vous faudra un pot en terre
cuite de soucoupe en terre cuite un
petit peu plus grande que votre peau une
perceuse de la corde les ciseaux de la
peinture acrylique de rondelles en inox
de préférence comme pour la précédente
voyez en fonction du diamètre de votre
corde et de la taille des trous dans les
soucoupes pour celle ci il s'agit de
percer les deux soucoupes au centre de
chacune
le pot en terre cuite devrait déjà avoir
un trou au fond et puis si c'est pas le
café devant un aussi
merci ensuite quatre trous au fond du
hope sur les côtés comme indiqué sur le
schéma ces trous serviront à faire
passer les graines donc prévoyez de les
faire assez large au moins un centimètre
de diamètre chaque une fois tous les
trous percés fête à neu à l'extrémité de
la corde fait passer d'abord la première
sous comme celle qui servira de plateau
de distribution fille le pot les troupes
vers le bas et enfin la première
rondelle pour bien bouché le trou de
fond du pot de fleurs fait un noeud au
dessus de la rondelle pour bien fixer le
tout tu enfiles et ensuite la deuxième
soucoupe beau retourner vers le haut
elle servira de toi pour les oiseaux et
surtout de protection pour la réserve de
graines dans le pot de fleurs rajouter
ensuite la deuxième modèle pour fermer
le toit ne fait surtout pas de quart
pour remplir la mangeoire il va falloir
soulevé la soucoupe
vous pouvez ensuite décoré la mangeoire
avec la peinture et même la dernière si
le coeur vous en dit
il est aussi possible de la fixer sur un
poteau au lieu de la suspendre ou sur un
mur et c'est au choix
voilà il ne vous reste plus qu'à remplir
de graines et attendre patiemment qu'une
boule de plumes veulent bien s'y
intéresser mais pour ça fait aussi
attention au placement de votre
mangeoire si les oiseaux ne s'y sent pas
en sécurité et de fortes chances pour
qu'ils préfèrent aller voir chez le
voisin quelques conseils donc pour bien
installer votre mangeoire installé là
dans un endroit qui offrent une bonne
visibilité aux oiseaux mais la plupart
de vos petits passereaux sont des proies
avant tout et il aime bien pouvoir voir
loin afin d'identifier les éventuelles
menaces avant qu'elles n'arrivent
exit donc la mangeoire calé au fond les
minuscules impasse sans visibilité et de
fortes chances pour que personne ne
vienne d'ailleurs tant qu on est sur le
sujet des dangers pour les aux yeux
assurez vous aussi que les chats n'ont
pas d'accès direct à la mangeoire ne
l'installez peint sur un mur et il y
avait des charentes quartier par exemple
bien éviter aussi les fourches des
arbres préférez les mangeoires suspendu
lé accroché sur moi même les mangeoires
sur auto mais suffisamment haute pour
empêcher minutes sauté dessus
et si vous approchez la mangeoire et
manche vérifiez bien que la branche en
question soient capables de supporter le
poids de la mangeoire et égrène ce
serait dommage je la retrouvais en
miettes sur le sol en fonction des
oiseaux que vous souhaitez attirer il
faut aussi savoir que certains
préféreront certains types de mangeoires
à d'autres les petits jours par exemple
ont tendance à manger au sol donc autre
leurre plutôt une assiette posé au sol
ça suffira les maisons sont de vrais
acrobates et adoreront les pins de grève
suspendue qu'elle picore vont la tête en
bas ici vous avez la chance d'avoir des
colibris dans le jardin il existe aussi
des mangeurs à l'hectare à remplir avec
de l'eau sucrée
concernant l'entretien des mangeoires il
faut bien évidemment les nettoyer
régulièrement et les désinfecter aussi
souvent que faire se peut et ce pour
éviter la propagation des parasites et
des maladies surtout dans le cas de la
nourriture qui prime comme les fruits
par exemple il faut nettoyer avant que
ça ne commence à pourrir
c'est et ça peut être dangereux pour nos
amis à plumes
le mieux c'est encore de serveurs une
petite quantité de nourriture à la fois
plus ce qu'il faut pour tenir un ou deux
jours comme ça à la nourriture on n'aura
pas le temps de se gâter et vous pourrez
facilement nettoyer vos mouchoirs vide
avant de les re remplir et si vous
mangez leur sont en bois vous pouvez
appliquer un traitement à huile de lin à
renouveler chaque année
si vous voulez plus idée sur comment
nourrir fausse oiseaux du jardin il
existe plein de petits livres avec pas
mal d'astuces
alors j'ai celui ci qui est plutôt
correct avec un bémol cependant il
propose une mixture pour nourrir à la
main des oisillons et là on touche un
point important que je voulais aborder
dans cette vidéo qui concerne
l'alimentation
ce gros bouquin la voilà c'est un livre
exclusivement dédié à l'élevage oiseaux
en captivité il contient plus d'une
vingtaine de mélanges différents pour
les jeunes oiseaux est un grand nom en
fait de variations pour ensuite les
adapter à chaque espèce qu'on arrive
donc à plusieurs centaines de recettes
différentes voire plus
très honnêtement j'ai pas compté mais
tout ça pour vous donner une idée de la
complexité en fait du sujet quand on
parle de l'alimentation et en plus ça
c'est un vieux bouquin de 87
donc on a encore progressé depuis d'où
le fait que ce genre de petits livres et
de petites recettes généralistes comme
présentés dans ce bouquin où on donne la
même chose à tout le monde
eh ben c'est pas top on se retrouve
ensuite avec des carences alimentaires
voire même un mauvais développement de
l'oisillon qui peuvent conduire à des
malformations
donc si vous n'êtes pas spécialiste
allez simplement donné loisirs au centre
de sauvegarde de la faune sauvage le
plus proche et ne tentez pas ces
mélanges un peu hasardeux l'oiseau vous
en remerciera plus tard et croyez moi
rien composant une mangeoire dans votre
jardin ou sur votre balcon vous aurez
déjà beaucoup aider les oiseaux de votre
quartier break
sur ce je vous souhaite bonne chance
dans vos futurs bricolage et je vous dis
à bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
avec des plumes
[Musique]